[music]
>> And I remember
or anyone chance meeting a non-Muslim we
cannot let go that opportunity.
There was a time anyone next to me
alhamdulillah. Now non-Muslim is there
we don't have time to sleep okay let's
try and get some rest. So we have a
non-Muslim
direct customer.
I want to do I'm not doing why? Because
when I land in the plane I'm giving a
lecture to maybe a thousand people or
ten thousand people. So if I do that I
will not I can't do that. So here I'm
using the Sharia logic let a small loss
take place to prevent a big loss.
I love INDIVIDUAL TALKING I LOVE IT
THAT'S MY CORE.
THE OPPORTUNITY I GET NOW IS thousand
times more than before but I cannot do
it why? Because if I do that what will
happen to my
talk.
People are gathering there.
The ten thousand people for the
opportunity there which will be seen to
millions. So one person inshallah will
forgive you. So that is the reason now
is your time.
What you can make most use of.
You cannot tell the person sitting next
to you
Mr. John
you know we have thirty minutes together
let's talk about Islam. Will he hear
you? Yes yes yes. What will he say? Most
probably he will say mind your own
business.
Or may courtesy say
I'm not interested in religion.
How to do Dawah to a person who's
sitting next to you?
You have only twenty minutes with him.
Is a technique.
If you ask a question brother John what
is the cross you're wearing?
This cross?
At the back of your mind
was Jesus Christ peace be upon him
crucified?
So when you ask him what is this cross
he may say you know this cross we
believe oh who's this then who's this
and then you start. Your matter is
there.
But you can't say okay now I want to
talk about religion he won't give you
time.
When you're asking a simple question
what is the [laughter] cross?
So one thing is how to initiate Dawah is
a technique.
You may be a very good driver.
But if you don't know how to start a car
your driving is useless.
I used to give this example till the
time it actually happened and let me
narrate this to you. It was about ten
years back more than ten years back.
Previously in my first Dawah training
program I said that without starting a
car you can't drive but didn't have any
example. That was in 1999 just a couple
of years after that one of my friends he
got a car
the BMW
and that time the latest 2001 model
and
he told his host that please go and park
my car.
So he goes
and he's coming back and he says
that I cannot find the ignition key.
I cannot find the
keyhole.
Did anyone realize the joke?
He could not find the keyhole.
He gave him the key he said I searched a
lot for five ten minutes I could not
find the
keyhole. What does it mean? Is it
possible or not possible?
Possible.
He's giving him a key and there's no
keyhole.
Possible?
We have a person from Japan.
Hi sir can you have the microphone here?
Here here Japanese.
I'd been to Japan one of the most
advanced countries. Yes brother. Yes
it's possible now. Huh? Uh well the key
without any like uh the iron but there
is automatic. Huh? The key we are
keyless ignition. It's automatic uh
ignition key.
Now technology has improved he's given
the right answer but not explained very
well.
See one thing is giving an answer.
One thing is giving a satisfying answer.
One thing is clarifying to people who
are not aware of it. A person who is
aware will understand. A person who is
not aware what do you mean? If you give
the explanation to a villager he won't
understand. Previously to start a car
there were levers in the key. Levers you
know seven lever key five lever key ten
lever key. If it matches it starts. Now
you have wireless matching through radio
control.
So when the key comes close to the car
automatically
you have to press the button to start
that's it. Start the engine by pressing.
Press the button engine starts. So when
you are carrying a key you don't have to
open the door with a key you open the
door because the moment the key comes
close to the door will open.
Good and bad. If you come close to your
car the robber can also open the car and
run away with the car you know that?
Really it's a fact. But
after you go the distance away from the
key the car will stop again.
Because the radioactivity has a certain
length. It is only active for hundred
meters or fifty meters or whatever it
is.
So this person is trying to say no key
so he's trying to laugh automatic. That
time most advanced now many cars have
that system. Therefore you know about
it. When I gave this example about five
ten years back people didn't know what
it is. Now it's coming.
Now even the small cars have this direct
radioactivity you just come close to it
and it starts.
So imagine you don't know this you're
expert driver.
You know what is a gear and what is a
steering wheel and how to take the turn
you don't know how to start the car.
All your driving skills are
useless.
So when you have a non-Muslim sitting
next to you
you have only ten minutes with him or
twenty minutes with him. You can't say
let's talk. Ask him a simple question
what is the cross? At the back of your
mind
was Christ peace be upon him crucified?
We'll deal with that.
You have the matter with you you have
done the training I know.
You cannot say okay now I want to talk
about was Jesus Christ peace be upon him
crucified? He's out of it all the time.
You ask him a question he say I'm a
Christian and we believe in Jesus who's
Jesus then it
starts.
Maybe you meet a Hindu who has a
vermilion on his head or maybe
if a lady is doing Dawah to a lady she's
wearing a mangalsutra. Mangalsutra means
it's a necklace of gold and black beads.
It has a certain significance we'll deal
with that later on. It gives an
opportunity for you to talk about Islam.
You know this cap?
This cap of mine very cheap.
It can do wonders. When I wear this cap
and a suit people say what is this cap?
Unknown person.
Kufi.
Very cheap opening doors.
They're looking at a person and on the
television suit tie who's this joker
suit tie wearing a cap?
Joker.
There was a trouser above the ankle
bigger joker.
Who is talking about Bible? Who is
talking about Veda? Let's hear him.
One way is to identify my label which we
shall deal inshallah. But it's opening
my doors for Dawah also. I'm wearing it
because it's a sunnah mainly.
Not because of it but it's having
multiple advantages. Opening doors.
For example it's the season of
Christmas.
Ask your Christian friend what is this
Christmas? Why do you celebrate
Christmas?
Oh Christmas?
Because our lord and savior Jesus Christ
was born on 25th December. Now you want
to talk about is Jesus God? Back of your
mind. You ask the question what is
Christmas? Indirect.
You ask a Christian I want to talk about
religion he say mind your own business
I'm not bothered. But when you talk then
he may tell yes you know I agree Bible
is illogical whatever it is. But you
initiate is important.
How to initiate is an art.
If you don't know how to initiate on one
to one Dawah all your knowledge would be
kept
in the box.
And depending upon the situation
now we come to doing Dawah with known
people.
Some people
you meet
as a colleague
maybe a schoolmate
maybe a colleague maybe at the
university maybe in the office you go.
You meet him everyday maybe five days a
week maybe you'll be meeting him for the
next few years.
Different technique. You have a neighbor
who's with you and may stay with you for
twenty years.
It's a technique.
How to do Dawah? I was in a medical
college and medical college in India you
find very few Muslims percentage wise
three four
percent are Muslims. Population has
twenty percent but medical college three
four.
When I used to have my lunch and I was
having lunch
with the friends
almost all of them non-Muslims.
Make a simple remark that if certain men
in the world are not allowed to marry
more than one woman woman as a whole
cannot live modestly.
What did you say?
I said I said if certain men in the
world are not allowed to marry more than
one woman woman as a whole can't live
modestly.
Are you talking about polygamy? I said
yes. What nonsense?
I said you want to know the answer? You
give me ten minutes. TEN MINUTES? I will
give you twenty minutes.
Now he's saying let's have fun with this
Muslim. Talking about polygamy that also
in a medical college.
I said so you want the answer?
Minimum ten minutes. Ten minutes? I will
give you 20 minutes. Now, when he's
willing to give time, his ears are open.
And you can shoot directly.
Shoot
the arrow of wisdom, hikmah, of love.
Not bullet, huh?
You have the answer of polygamy or
polygyny.
You tell him, "I want to talk to you
about the principles of Islam." You say,
"Okay, fine. You mind your own
business." Now, this friend of yours,
whether John or whether Tom,
he's asking you for time now.
So, how to instigate
your non-Muslim friend to ask you for
doing Dawah on him
is a technique.
An opportunity missed is an opportunity
lost.
My answer is there.
They are thinking, "Let's have fun." I'm
thinking, "Let's do Dawah."
Both are giving time.
You know what? Eve teasing is common.
Eve teasing is common in the colleges.
It's becoming more and more. Do you know
where you get this word Eve teasing
from?
No one knows.
Uh English language.
Eve teasing, where you get the word Eve
teasing?
Eve, there are two people raising their
hands. Time is short. Eve
It is you know Adam and Eve.
Eve is another word using for female.
It's come from there.
Everyone knows Adam and Eve. Everyone
knows Adam and Eve. Raise your hand.
But only two from you knew that it comes
from the root word Eve, that means
teasing a lady. It's called as bird
watching. You know bird watching?
You know what's bird watching? Bird
watching. Everyone knows bird watching.
Hope you don't do it, huh?
There are two types of bird watching.
One is actual bird and one is
different bird, you know?
So, don't do If you go for actual bird,
watching the pigeons and watching the
stork is no problem. But otherwise,
it's not Islamic. So, someone is Eve
teasing in the college. I just make a
statement
that what if that girl was your sister?
If someone teases your sister. If
someone teases my sister, I'll break his
neck. I'll break his arm.
You want to tease somebody else's sister
and you think it is good. Now, somebody
teases your sister, you want to break
his arm and break his neck. I say, "It's
illogical." No, no, you know, "MY SISTER
WILL NOT DRESS up like her."
Back of my mind,
I want to talk about hijab.
So, when I want to talk about hijab, I'm
talking about Eve teasing.
Otherwise, who will agree for hijab?
Then my answer is there.
So, answer is there in your hard disk.
All you have got trained.
But if you're not trained to start the
discussion, all your training is
useless.
Igniting, ignition, starting,
instigating for good work.
Alhamdulillah.
Surah An-Nahl, chapter 16, verse 125.
Invite all to the way of thy Lord with
wisdom and beautiful preaching and argue
with them and reason with them in the
ways that are best and most gracious.
This is the technique.
So, you have Dawah one-to-one with known
people, Dawah with unknown people, you
have less time, few minutes, few hours,
different technique. You have a neighbor
who's there.
You're meeting every day.
How you make use of your opportunity is
a technique.
>> [music and singing]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.